[Musique]
je crois qu'on devrait quitter je peux
forcément de faire changer ma vie il
faut mieux tiré
mais je compte pas laisser tomber je
suis copain peut voir heureusement que
tu es trouver les paper d'inquiétude
c'est c'est moi qui t'ai demandé de
venir je te rappelles tu as disparu
pendant toute une semaine pour arriver à
ce concentré il n'y a rien de mieux que
de se faire larguer ça aurait pu se
passer autrement
attends je reformule ça va se passer
autrement me dis pas que tu crois que
c'est ce que je crois que tu crois que
c'est ça une machine temporelle
j'ai fabriqué ce que to make largué
rêverait d'avoir une deuxième chance
je trouve que tu es la meilleure c'est
gentil merci beaucoup stillman tiedemann
merde on a vraiment remonter le temps on
peut aller n'importe où faire ce qu'on
veut on doit récupérer débit et si moi
aussi j'ai rangé un peu mon année
pourrie ouais quand tu penses tu as quoi
sur la tête là du minoxidil j'ai acheté
ce truc l'an dernier mais je m'en suis
jamais servi mais on a vu ce que ça a
donné
[Musique]
evans on va prendre les escaliers
c'était un super match je l' ai gagnée
pour toi ah ouais c'était pas terrible
comme approche
salut
[Musique]
cette appli
reste avec moi dans ce moment
parfaitement imparfait
pas réussi à améliorer plein de trucs
vous allez sûrement vous remettre
ensemble mais casser la machine
non mais je peux seulement avancer dans
le temps il faut que j'arrive à tout
réussir du premier coup
deuxième tu veux dire on s'en fout
je
j'arrive pas à croire que tu n'as presse
[Musique]
je veux pas que ça s'arrête
je nous renvoie chez nous or 25 secondes
je vais aller jeter un oeil à ma
nouvelle bouche ok tu me rejoins vannes
non non non non non non attends attends
dont c'était mal
[Musique]